Навпроти мене Радослав Сікорський
колишній міністр закордонних справ Польщі
Пане Сікорський, дякую, що погодилися на інтерв'ю
Скажіть, Ваш імідж русофоба - це маячня?
Коли Радянський Союз окупував мою країну
як це було у 80-х
я був ворогом Радянського Союзу
Коли це припинилося, Росія та Польща як сусіди повинні мати нормальні відносини.
Я працював заради встановлення саме таких прагматичних відносин з Росією
І в мене були успіхи
Ідеться про роботу російських і польських істориків
Також ми запровадили безвізовий режим
між Калінінградською областю
та прилеглою територією Польщі
Це результат нашої трирічної спільної роботи із Сергієм Лавровим і європейськими колегами
ми переконали Європейський Союз змінити закон, щоб це уможливити
Але було й інше
Президент Путін приїхав у Гданськ на сімдесятирічну річницю
початку Другої світової війни
і це було важливим сигналом, що він визнає
що Друга світова війна почалася саме тут, у Польщі
а не підтримує сталінські погляди на історію
відповідно до яких війна почалася
лише у 41-му році
Це було важливо
Ми також вважаємо успіхом той факт
що президент Путін був першим російським лідером, який відвідав Катинь
місце жахливого злочину, де радянський НКВС
розстріляв двадцять тисяч польських військовополонених
Ми думали, що це нормалізує
наші сусідські відносини
Але втрутилися три факти
перше - це захоплення
аншлюс Криму та вторгнення в Україну
друге - те, що сама Росія більше не хоче зближуватися із Заходом
Тепер люди забули
але до 2011-2012 років
Росія обговорювала угоду про партнерство та співробітництво з Євросоюзом
запровадження всеохоплюючої
зони вільної торгівлі
Але в певний момент Росія вирішила
що вона хоче бути суперником Євросоюзу
і вибудовувати альтернативний полюс інтеграції
з Білоруссю, Казахстаном, Вірменією та Україною
Це, звісно, змінило динаміку
І третій факт
це, звісно, трагічна катастрофа польського президентського літака в Росії
І те, що ми нині бачимо в Польщі
як Росія жорстоко та без поваги
ставиться до уламків нашого борту номер один
Цей літак - наша власність
Те, що Росія не повертає його, ми сприймаємо як зневагу Польщі
Через це психологія наших відносин змінилася
Чи правильно я вас зрозуміла
що ті звинувачення, які звучать з боку чинного уряду щодо попередників
про те, що ризики, які йдуть від Росії, недооцінювалися, частково справедливі?
Ні. Тому що я був серед тих міністрів
які попереджали Захід
що Грузія - це передвісник
Ми звертали увагу тоді на те
що президент Путін говорив
на саміті НАТО в Бухаресті
що Україна - це штучно створена держава
Ми казали, що це небезпечно
Що це означає, що Росія не змирилася
із втратою імперії
з  незалежністю України, її правом на окреме існування
Ми говорили, що будуть наслідки
І я можу довести це
дякую WikiLeaks за публікацію дипломатичних послань США
ви там можете прочитати
що саме я говорив, зокрема,
своїм американським колегам
Але також я відкрив польське консульство
у Севастополі
І вже після анексії Криму
це було єдине представництво країни
Євросоюзу в Криму
У нас був постійний потік інформації про те,
що відбувається
Ми можете назвати чинний польський уряд русофобським?
Коли російські генерали погрожують ядерною зброєю
що ми повинні відчувати?
Коли Росія проводить навчання "Захід"
під час яких Польщу називають
ціллю ядерного удару?
Це ефективний шлях підтримки фобії
Що мене хвилює, то це те, що зараз
здається, у нас узагалі немає ніяких відносин
Ми спілкуємося через ЗМІ, це означає
кричати один на одного через замкову шпарину
І це може бути небезпечно
тому що це створює простір для непорозумінь
Важливо також розуміти
що чинна правляча партія в Польщі,
ідеологічно кажучи
не відрізняється від "Єдиної Росії"
у них, як у всіх націоналістичних популістів,
немає протиріч
Це важливе зауваження ви зробили
Справді, якщо подивитися на правлячу польську партію "Право і справедливість"
яка нині вважається популістською правою партією
і, з іншого боку, на їхніх колег
з інших популістських партій
Центральної та Східної Європи
видно, що в основному популісти люблять Путіна
тому що вони мають спільні цінності
зокрема говорять про збереження традиційного устрою суспільства
Вони націоналісти, євроскептики
негативно налаштовані щодо об'єднаної Європи
Але це не стосується польських популістів
Я маю на увазі Качинського та Путіна
Я не розумію
Тому що є фундаментальні відмінності між ними
та правими популістами в Європі
У тих немає кордонів з Росією. А у нас є
І вони ніколи не були окуповані Росією
Росія взагалі-то повинна бути занепокоєна тим
що в неї погані відносини…
Ну, от Чехія була окупована…
Але немає спільного кордону
І Чехія не бачить, знаєте, як ми почуваємося ціллю
Ось це якраз про фобію.
Це про те, що Росія - єдина реально можлива загроза для Польщі
Ми не думаємо, що це актуальна загроза
але Росія проводить навчання з такими сценаріями
І деякі російські політики говорять такі речі
які виглядають небезпечними
Тож, багато людей у Польщі побоюються Росії
Це означає, що підхід чинного уряду
можна назвати прагматичним?
Ні, я вважаю, вони перебільшують
Я вважаю, що страх не повинен паралізувати вас
страх не повинен змушувати вас
говорити те, що дискредитує вашу позицію
Я вважаю, що Польща доволі велика
щоб ігнорувати деякі нерозсудливі заяви
наприклад, пана Жириновського
А що він каже, до речі?
О, він каже
що відповідно до російських воєнних планів, Польща буде знищена
Але водночас у розпал української кризи
він писав мені листа, в якому пропонував Польщі
забрати п'ять провінцій Західної України
Що ви відповіли?
Нічого не відповів
Але, як ви можете собі уявити,
все це змушує нас думати
що в Росії є політики, які мислять категоріями
30-х років минулого століття
Чи правда, що ви якось сказали, вас цитували
що якщо раптом Росія спробує завоювати Польщу
польська армія, як ви сказали,
"розквасить їм обличчя"?
Тобто Польща достатньо сильна, щоб чинити опір?
Я вважаю, що Україна виявилася доволі
складною ціллю для російської агресії
Польща, звісно, боролась б
У нас нині 18-й в світі за обсягами
військовий бюджет
І ми відповіли б на напад
Я не думаю, що Росія могла б виграти війну
з Польщею без мобілізації
Ми також частина найсильнішого
в світі військового альянсу
Тому, знаєте
вам краще не пробувати
Але при цьому є російські політики,
які погрожують нам
А коли вам погрожують, ви відповідаєте
Давайте перейдемо до нинішньої політики безпеки
яку проводить польський уряд
Відповідно до заяви міністра оборони,
яку він зробив у серпні
він сказав, що Польща хоче розмістити
американську базу на своїй території
щоб стримувати Росію від можливого нападу
Які "за" і "проти" такого рішення? Ви підтримуєте це?
Якби ви запитали будь-яку людину в Німеччині,
або ж у Росії, або в Україні
п'ять-десять років тому, невже Росія захопить Крим,
Вам би відповіли: "Ні, звісно ж, ні. Це неможливо"
Але це сталося
Ви утримуєте армію як страховку від того,
що може трапитися
хоча й не видається імовірним
І тому кожна країна в світі має плани дій
на випадок непередбачених конфліктів
Непередбачених, але можливих
Під час холодної війни на території Німеччини було 300 тисяч американців
щоб стримувати Радянський Союз
У Польщі, звісно, є своя армія,
але вона також хоче заощадити
То ви за це рішення?
Я дуже багато працював,
щоб довести це рішення до кінця
Ми хочемо, щоб у Польщі були розміщені союзні сили
які б стримували Росію
але не погрожували б Росії
Дві бригади - саме про такий масштаб американської військової присутності йдеться
і це саме те, що обговорювалося між
американськими і російськими військовими
на етапі нашого приєднання до НАТО
І я вважаю це розумним
Ви не можете вторгнутися в Росію з двома бригадами. Чи не так?
Вермахт спробував із сотнею дивізій і зазнав поразки
Тож, дві бригади не погрожують Росії
але надають упевненості Польщі
Чи правильно я зрозуміла, що ви вважаєте
що варто покладатися на США у питанні гарантування безпеки країни
тому що раніше ви говорили,
що краще в цьому питанні
покладатися на Європейський Союз
Дві страховки - краще, ніж одна
Тому в нас має бути американський страховий поліс
А враховуючи те, що Дональд Трамп у Білому домі
який поводився дуже дивно на прес-конференції з президентом Путіним
ми не знаємо, що президент Трамп зробить у випадку кризи з Росією
Це одна з багатьох причин, чому я вважаю
що Європейський Союз має також мати військову політику
яка відповідає його статусу
Я дуже радий, що в новому багаторічному бюджеті Євросоюзу
вперше передбачені десять мільярдів євро на оборону
Нам вони потрібні здебільшого на півдні
Ми повинні захистити південний кордон Європейського Союзу від масової міграції
наприклад, тому що я вважаю, що кордон на Сході
це серйозна робота для НАТО
Що б Ви сказали про можливу реакцію Росії
на появу у вас тут у Польщі
постійної військової бази США?
У нас вже є постійна присутність військ НАТО в країнах Балтії
У нас є дві американські бази в Румунії
Росія вийшла з договору про звичайні збройні сили в Європі
який обмежував присутність звичайних військ
Це пояснюють тим, що Росія, мовляв
повинна мати можливість пересувати війська на своїй території на свій розсуд
Гаразд, якщо ви можете пересувати, як вам заманеться
то й НАТО так може
Можливо, я помиляюся
але зараз ви говорите як прихильник чинного польського уряду
принаймні з точки зору політики безпеки,
з точки зору того
як вони оцінюють та уявляють загрози
Це хибне враження?
Чинний уряд багато про це говорить
але не модернізує збройні сили так,
як я вважав би за необхідне
Нині Польща витрачає на оборону
понад 10 мільярдів доларів на рік
Але ми повинні закуповувати певні серйозні оборонні системи
а ми цього не робимо
Мені подобаються росіяни в Росії
Але коли росіяни приходять зі зброєю в руках
незваними в мою країну чи чужу
тоді я чиню опір цьому.